o no
[Música]
a escala en parís
braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español
la convención constitucional chilena
será instalada el próximo domingo 4 de
julio su tarea elaborar el nuevo
proyecto de constitución que reemplace a
aquella que fui que está actualmente en
vigor y que fue establecida impuesta
durante la dictadura de augusto pinochet
que gobernó ese país entre 1973 y hasta
1990 la convención constitucional es el
fruto de las protestas sociales que
tuvieron lugar en el país sudamericano a
partir de octubre del 2019 y también de
la votación que tuvo lugar en mayo
pasado de la cual salieron 155
integrantes que deberán redactar el
proyecto de nueva constitución que
además será sometido al referéndum para
que sea aprobada definitivamente para
hablar del significado histórico de esta
decisión de sus implicaciones de lo que
puede cambiar para la población chilena
saludamos aquí en este escala en parís a
la escritora y realizador a franco
chilena carmen castillo carmen
bienvenida a esta escala en parís
muchas gracias por la invitación brave
es un placer tenerla con nosotros
carmen usted es chilena de nacimiento
salió de su país en 1975 en plena
dictadura militar su vida es fuerza
expulsada salió de su país expulsada
efectivamente durante la dictadura
militar su vida estuvo en peligro salió
herida tras un ataque de la dictadura
militar exiliada en francia país que la
acogió evidentemente con los brazos
abiertos y que representa para usted
visto en distancia el llegar a este
referéndum a esta creación de la
convención constitucional chilena es la
lucha permanente por qué
el acontecimiento imprevisible de la
rebelión de octubre del 19 está
presidido por una permanencia de la de
la lucha a veces minoritaria a veces
derrotada y saliendo de la derrota
aquello que llamamos la sabiduría de la
derrota es
no pensaba vivirlo a la escala de mi
vida y es siempre una lección para mí
para nuestra generación para todos
pensar que aquella memoria de los
vencidos aquella memoria de las luchas
que dejaron una promesa incumplida de
repente ahí están es decir como no lo
lograron cómo es
atravesamos todo este tiempo
en una lucha tan desigual y sin embargo
tan potente porque lo que surge y lo que
viví en el a partir del 18 de octubre
del 19 es la emergencia de ese pasado es
las figuras que como allende miguel
enrique víctor jara la canción es decir
quién le dio densidad al ya basta todas
esas personas que hace 50 años ya
buscaban precisamente una transformación
social profunda de chile carmen castillo
una pregunta es justamente esa revuelta
popular que emerge en octubre del 19 que
recordemos fue por el aumento de los
precios del metro de sus origen de lo
que son las alas a la superficie mucha
gente se la descubrió como algo que no
se esperaba como algo inédito con algo
inesperado a usted también le sorprendió
esto o había algo que fermentaba que
hizo que finalmente el volcán explotara
todo estaba ahí pero no se sabe cuando
aquello de la apuesta a lo incierto no
está allí las razones por la cual
revelarse las razones en chile y en todo
el planeta de luchar de exigir una vida
digna una vida con justicia con igualdad
están allí pareciera que no pero en
chile venía precedido por una como decía
no por movimientos sociales fuertes
potentes que habían marcado desde desde
la lucha contra la dictadura en el 80
habían ido marcando que era posible que
aquel sistema cruel en el que vivimos en
chile un sistema uno de los más crueles
del mundo el liberalismo por cierto es
una sociedad neoliberal perfecta todo
estaba perfecto bajo la constitución de
pinochet no había cómo salirse de esos
márgenes y él
y no la mentalidad del consumo del
dinero de estamos bien somos los tigres
de américa latina'
y allí en esa sociedad la vida de la
gente yo siempre lo decía hace años ya
pero este es una sociedad de una
crueldad espantosa donde la barbarie
donde la miseria ha tomado un rostro que
es difícil de detectar y en esa
situación en esa situación el estallido
que yo lo llamo rebelión popular y
social sería una rebelión ciudadana así
es carmen castillo evidentemente va a
pasar nueve meses antes de que sepamos
qué texto saldrá de el trabajo de estos
155 integrantes de la asamblea
constituyente desde su punto de vista
cuál podría ser la o las dos ejemplos
más importantes de reforma que incluya
la constitución sabiendo lo decimos
chile ha sido un faro del neoliberalismo
ausencia de estado privatización del
agua educación privatizada pero cuáles
podrían ser dos elementos que usted
piense puedan servir que más
una ruptura con respecto a lo que fue
excelencia
expresada en la constitución de gusto
pinochet más allá de todo lo que es la
la
permitir más allá de permitir la paridad
la igualdad de género más allá yo creo
que el punto central es atacar lo que
esta constitución defiende que es la
privatización la propiedad privada en
esta constitución no ha permitido ni
siquiera luchar contra la privatización
del agua en chile todo es una mercancía
virtualmente todo entonces la batalla en
la constitución es por lograr
que las bases de una sociedad en que la
propiedad social en que la igualdad y
que es la igualdad la igualdad no es una
conquista de un día para otro la
igualdad es el xxi uno tiene que estar
consciente de ella actuar y ejecutarla y
eso es lo que vivimos en chile desde
hace ya más de un año la igualdad como
conciencia a este propósito carmen
estamos hablando justamente de las
protestas que dieron origen a lo que es
ahora la prevención convención
constitucional las protestas de octubre
del 2019 en este marco también surgen
otras formas de protesta que es el de
las mujeres mujeres que luchan por el
respeto de sus cuerpos por el respeto
como seres humanos porque finalmente
dicen ellas el violador eres tú se
dirigen al estado se dirigen al sistema
capitalista el mejor ejemplo de esto no
sabemos es esa canción es mejor
el violador eres tú del grupo las tesis
que representa para usted este despertar
de ese sector de mujeres jóvenes
adultas de todas las edades que han
salido a las calles también a
reivindicar su espacio dentro de la
sociedad en igualdad de condiciones es
fundamental es porque la poética de la
emancipación y de la lucha de las
mujeres en chile se expandió con esta
performance extraordinaria que ha
circulado por el planeta entero se ha
reproducido
esa fuerza de las tesis del grupo de
valparaíso repercusión todas las
generaciones
pero uno veía desde desde antes del 18
de octubre del 2019 la gran marcha que
presidió aquello era la marcha feminista
es decir la lucha feminista la poética
la invención la creatividad de las
formas de lucha de las mujeres en chile
de todos los sectores sociales unidas de
todas las generaciones de todos los
colores es lo que marcó siempre tiene
que haber una imagen un impacto que
produce una poética y esa poética de las
calles de chile fue dada por las mujeres
y el angel de la barricada el ángel de
la barricada que son los ángeles que
estuvieron que cubrieron las murallas
son los espíritus de los muertos que
vienen a acompañar a las generaciones en
lucha
ese abrazo entre la generación entre los
muertos y los vivos no no es una forma
de decir mío se vivió se vivió se
transformó se inventó se liberó la
palabra se
experimentó la igualdad y aquello que
imborrable son instantes de eternidad
que a pesar de toda la represión
violencia policial 460 personas sin
visión de la visión bron mil preso la
lucha para para liberar a los presos
jóvenes de la revuelta ha sido una lucha
pero inmensa y ahí estamos y a pesar de
eso a pesar de la pandemia asambleas
populares solidario garantizará tenida
elección victoria carmen castillo
ustedes decíamos además escritora es
realizadora cuenta en su haber con más
de 23 películas por tome trajes
documentales el primero de ellos fue
allá por 1983 los muros de santiago el
más reciente es los controladores de la
sombra una inversión por el mundo de las
prisiones de los hospitales
psiquiátricos hay una constante un filo
conductor en sus trabajos la memoria la
memoria de los de abajo
quisiera o sea es para mí ha sido una
una manera de vivir la fidelidad a lo
que hemos sido creo que uno va
inventando las formas de lucha creo como
decía daniel bensaid que el 89 marcó un
hito en nuestra forma de pensar nuestra
visión del mundo
que había que a partir de ahí continuar
y en esa apuesta de continuar me
encontré gracias al exilio porque el
exilio guarda y nos regala también cosas
muy importantes y a mí me regaló el cine
como un instrumento de trabajo de la
memoria de los vencidos de la memoria y
de la realidad de los invisibles y he
tratado pero también en fin
ha sido una de mis manera no de poder
el cine no cambia nada pero pero uno
cuenta historias sin duda alguna no nos
queda más tiempo lamentablemente yo
quisiera simplemente decirle a nuestro
público que evidentemente carmen
castillo es una autora que sigue muy
activa próximamente a partir del mes de
octubre en la generalidad de cataluña
tendrá lugar una exposición a propósito
de el exilio chileno una perspectiva de
lo que representa para estas personas
estas gentes precisamente el haber
pasado tener que salir de su país una
cosa que no se no se decide sino que se
impone digamos ya al final de esta
escala en parís
realmente astilló mil gracias por haber
venido a nuestros estudios recuerdo que
usted es escritora y realizadora chilena
franco-chilena muchísimas gracias a
ustedes les damos otra cita la próxima
semana aquí en otra escala en parís
[Música]